yo what's up guys prestige here last
time we left off and my hair brown
Survivor Series I was kind of ups hiding
from the stupid cave spiders man so yeah
I'm hiding from the cave spiders because
they were wrecking me so hard and
hopefully I'll be able to seek some six
and glorious vengeance if I died I would
suck so bad okay I'm getting some black
one sec I don't need for far okay I'm
gonna want to destroy all this cobweb
you know what you know I'm gonna break
this there I was going to do you can
still do stop okay see they see they get
all they get all glitched out and I like
can't fight them it's really annoying I
just see if I can break the spawner it's
better than neutralizing it stopped
being poisoned you know if I nice had
some milk right now look at all milk yes
I my plan is just when i'm done
exploring to a well okay let's go oh not
not no no no no no oh ok the poison
can't kill me or better not kill me good
are we good yeah okay can't kill me even
though I'm planning hard poison doesn't
kill oh I was like hooker I'm gonna go
break the spawn or no ambushed so we're
gonna chill here I really just want to
get the short stuff mer I will he loots
she'd sack that ok let's drop stuff I
don't need I don't need this I don't
need this I don't need this I don't need
dirt I'll keep the string sticks okay
don't need this
like that ok now let's wait a little bit
longer for that let's generate so for
all of you better newly the series is my
hair round Survivor Series unfortunately
hair brown will not be with us because i
had the mod that made a little more
popular but in the game and
unfortunately the mod is not up to 1.5
standard so for a few episodes will have
to go without him but that's ok because
we just found an abandoned after and i'm
attempting to progress through it but
the stupid spiders making it quite
difficult come on come on come on yeah
ok we're all good i watch out for ambush
because the a bunch of them already
spawned i hear so many zombies ok poison
me but how what the heck poison go away
dang i dropped my shovel dang it ok
let's not go that way yeah also if you
notice i have smooth lighting off just
because i don't have a lot to find i'm
going to tad bit of lag gladly leggy
leave this place ha hair burn her burn
still trolling he's not even in the game
right now or supposed not in the game I
said that exact same thing last time
yeah I won't get more than a stack of
rails but getting this iron will be very
beneficial I want to get melon seed if I
get Mel and sees that I'm probably just
gonna bail as soon as that happens how
many I gotta get up in rails but i'm
going to leave the coal here for now
because it's gonna take too long I just
I want to get out of here as soon as
possible hello Jean vishesh it allowed
annoying people that I've been hearing
don't want to get attacked on the side
rhombus thank you thank you for dying
it's much appreciated
let's get that iron block you you
annoying nuisance not on block you yeah
alright pick you up I want you to find a
chest with some melon seeds chest with
sham marriage I will pick up that iron
dad iron wrought iron mined at iron aha
break my way back up you hope your
skeleton code or we can get like 10 more
they break so fast it's quite nice okay
one over a stack so I need to get
anything I'll go back ok let's go back
the way I came since there was a path I
could take a dot away this is just flood
did let's see if I can block it off oh
dang it looks like it's like opening up
to the freaking ocean man I was just get
the chest dang it pumpkin seeds co no no
no no Oh Frick no oh my gosh no no no no
no oh my gosh i wanna lose a lot goods
let's go let's go all right what Oh
creepers uh take no I want it creepers
freaking I'm safe from her around
nothing these dumb creepers Oh like 400
armor no I feel like I'm just like dang
it i need explore full iron armor ah ok
i think was this way because it was the
i was that it was the freakin more more
view he gone he gone oh my gosh
oh my freaking gosh no I think it was
this way last time I blocked some water
and not yeah okay there was this way oh
my gosh no oh my good good okay we're at
the mine shaft it's good right so it's
only going to be in spots that are lit
up where this way come visit me
something is quite hair bun it's not
that way ah down here no just no dang it
now goods are you know worth the heck is
it this way things this way oh my gosh
yeah that's up here it's uh Peter
anything yeah I remember going up this
okay wait wait wait wait come on come on
word the creeper blow up was going back
I was going through here oh I think I
found it oh my gosh i can get my good
book yes my goods goods off of like 27
are you kidding me oh like my stuff went
everywhere no I did have like full iron
armor
I can't pick anything else up I screw
that screw that oh my gosh at least I
got this stuff back Oh screw you screw
no no no oh you're gonna get it you're
gonna get it all okay yeah I'm getting
out of here now oh my god all freaking
heck
I swear I swear if a creeper comes upon
me okay I'm just going to check to see
if it as friggin chest nope nope okay
i'm leaving because i want i did say i
wanted to melon seeds oh my gosh I can't
believe I got my stuff back I lost 20
levels oh my frick hirsch that was
stressful ah oh wow this is my hair
braun series and if this stressful
without hair burn so I I can imagine
when her brain starts really freaking
pouring lava on me when I mining how
much fun that's going to be 0 here sheep
sheep save me from the start doc rawr oh
my gosh Oh your cow idiotic cows
minecraft you saved me pulled me into
your sweet idiocy yes come on yes yes
sweet sunlights ah that is actually
really close to my house like I went
down and then I went so I went far back
so I went far back behind my house that
I went back straight under and then the
band my chest and my chapstick around
there oh the main thing I wanted was
like all this iron those the main thing
I wanted well I have this now okay up
all bulk materials going there beating
up old materials
this is all bulk material and bulk bulk
bulck bulck bulck bulck either signs I
picked up from hair burn much oh my gosh
at least now I have another iron
chestplate so when like their tour
Warren I can make a good one that was
freaking stressful that's what s full of
38 stray I got so much strength pumpkin
seeds steak check out this this goes me
10 64 rails not one rail more oh gosh I
was freaking stress fall well I'll spice
more sugar cane yeah my minecraft can
definitely be like uber stressful for
like uber chill like when you're just
like farming like an a I got a bunch of
wheat just so peaceful in your building
then you like going to the mine shafts
it's freaking death from above and below
and the sides and everywhere you're
shaking you're all done 26 gold nice
want to find a village so much tumblr
have all the Hummer from don't have
enough time in this video let me go to
find a village next video I'm going to
try finding a bit at sea fish actually
don't you know just cuz the stupid
creeper killed me up now I don't want
that one on all nine worlds because that
stupid creeper freaking blew me up
better not be able to blow me up now if
a creeper can blow me up in full iron
what what in full iron armor that's one
for a good creeper oh I know I wonder
next video I'm going to expand the house
out that's what I'm going to do
actually hmm i'm going to start that oh
no come back I think I've time to start
that now do i'll check one truck out of
time hey you guys pretty accustomed so
if you've seen this series you're pretty
accustomed to getting a glimpse of my
laptop I'll me with my laptop my desktop
i'm not i don't even use a laptop at you
put it on a desktop it's a background so
i'm going crazy so after that extremely
stressful portion of minecraft we're
going to do some nice little peaceful
minecraft with all some building yeah i
think we're going to expand it i'm going
to put fences on the sides let's give it
let's get the fences fences one I want
to do this like have it kind of like
that's like the pathway so it's kind of
like an open pathway but uh i'll show
you don't you worry okay let's what's a
half you give me two stacks and now
let's unstick you it your way i'll give
me enough sticks
boop-boop-boop-boop good 12 inch HP
enough so yeah we'll make it that big so
just 32 a walkway and poop really one
short and now that would be way too long
we're going to have three at the max
probably going to short attack shorten
it down to two and then I'm going to
start on a bit like that there's no
point in having nayana we'll see we'll
see what I'm feeling
Nick connecting section just for more
space oh yeah and i think i will put
like that yeah and let me do something
different for the roof oh no all right
guys well I hope you all enjoy this semi
stressful video my name is prestige if
you like this I would appreciate it if
you rate it if you comment Andrea if you
got this far I think you enjoyed it i
think it deserves a like so that would
be much appreciated and make sure if you
to share our favorite and if you do
subscribe our guys prestige piece up